let's go to i believe this is kendall
from is it san mateo
it's sort of too long for me to see i
know it's kendall though
can you hear me david yes i can it's uh
san marcos texas oh san marcos okay very
good
yeah sorry i'm super white so i always
pronounced the san marcos
um no so my question was
is with um i had it pulled up here
with the gsa um
uh the gsa announcing that they'd be
letting the transition go through
um have you noticed i just wanted to do
your take on the
notable further breakdown what seems of
trump's psyche as he's been tweeting
because
after the gsa uh tweet or sent out the
letter
and trump said he would be allowing the
gsa he's been
retweeting just some really strange
things from like actors especially
he's been he looks like he retweeted
randy quaid like
four times listen what's going on with
trump is
he is furious that the attention is
shifting to joe biden as it should
because trump has given up on the virus
and biden is now running a coronavirus
task force
joe biden's building a cabinet joe biden
will soon be president
and what's what you are seeing are the
last
gasps of trump's narcissistic ego
and so he just can't stop and the
my guess is that trump tweeting that
he's allowing the transition to go
forward even though he still thinks he
won
i think that that is likely to be as
close as we get to a concession from
donald trump
but i would expect him to continue
tweeting for a while
when the election is certified on
december 14th
he may start doing less of it and we may
even see trump just kind of go off to
mar-a-lago around christmas time and
never come back to dc
but this is all ego driven what you are
seeing right now
right i it was just when i woke up this
morning i always you know
i check i have google read me the news
and then i go through twitter
and i always check and see if if trump
has done something
incredibly stupid and all i see is is
ranty quaid
yeah it's uh there's no i don't know
that there's really any rhyme or reason
sometimes trump will do 80 retweets in
the middle of the night
sometimes he'll be very quiet trump
hasn't taken questions
from the press for for nearly a month
and i would be i would
expect that to continue for a while
quite frankly but
we're just going to have to deal with
and deal with it until he finally goes
okay well thank you david and if you
ever end up in san marcos
i know you're a big uh foodie so if you
ever end up in san marcos definitely try
um a cafe on the square it's a
restaurant downtown it's real good
all right very good i appreciate the
recommendation
give a good one all right you too take
care uh there we go
checking in there from uh from texas
a lot of viewers a lot of viewers in
texas i want to let you know that our
sponsor vincero watches is having a
massive holiday sale on all of their
products right now
and you can take advantage of it by
going to davidpakman.com
watch a brand new high quality wrist
swatch really is the perfect way
to add something fresh to your style
whether it's for you
or a gift for someone else vincero is a
brand that has a serious dedication to
the craft of watchmaking which is really
evident when you look closely at their
watches
i wear vincero watches myself lately
i've been wearing one from their icon
automatic collection it's the mesh matte
black watch and i love the sleek
minimalist design
their watches are actually sold at a
fair price their mission has always been
to make a wristwatch
from high-end materials but one that
everyday people can afford
and that's why they have over 25 000
5 star reviews because you won't find a
better made watch
for this great of a price anywhere else
you can get big holiday discounts on all
of their products right now
and free shipping when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video